en el último vídeo les estaba platicando
acerca de mi dilema sobre el paquete de
jabones aromáticos que nos regalaron y
bueno recuerda que mi esposa lo que hizo
fue tomarnos estos tres jabones y
dividirlos a la mitad y fue justo en ese
momento en el cual nos dimos cuenta que
él imparte en la parte que me tocaba de
los jabones es lo mismo que 3 entre 2
que es exactamente lo mismo que 3 por un
medio que es exactamente lo mismo que
tres medios y bueno esto esto aquí los
tres medios quiero que lo visualice
siempre como 3 entre 2 esto es lo mismo
que dividir 3 entre 2
muy bien y si nosotros lo queremos ver
en una recta numérica pues qué te parece
si nosotros nos tomamos aquí una recta
numérica para ver si así podemos
entender mejor el concepto así que voy a
hacer una recta por aquí o que algo más
o menos así y bueno esta herramienta me
gusta mucho porque dan líneas rectas
este es mi eje y imagínate que aquí
tengo al cero si aquí tengo al cero
entonces
y por acá tengo al 1 por acá tengo al 1
entonces aquí aquí tengo un medio aquí
tengo un medio y hasta por acá si por
acá tengo el 2
imagínate que por acá tengo al 2
entonces justo aquí a la mitad tendría
un entero con un medio
un medio y bueno realmente cuando yo me
tomo tres medios de estos jabones
visualizado aquí en esta barra de
jabones me estaría tomando tres partes
de un medio esto quiere decir que si
aquí tengo a la unidad a me voy a tomar
una primera parte aquí tengo una primera
parte va a ser esta parte de aquí
después a esta primera parte le voy a
agregar otra segunda parte me voy a
tomar ahora esta otra segunda parte esto
de aquí ya esto le voy a agregar otra
tercera parte otra tercera parte que va
a ser esta de ti de tal manera que voy a
tener un medio otro medio y otro medio
tengo tres medios igual date cuenta que
llegamos al valor de un entero un medio
justo aquí estamos en un entero un medio
es decir medio jabón antes que dos
jabones enteros y de hecho eso es muy
cierto tú no puedes visualizar justo
aquí aquí tengo un jabón y medio y no
llegó a los dos jabones
qué quiere decir que 3 entre 2 es
exactamente lo mismo que dividir 3 entre
2 y esto es lo mismo que 12 cabe una vez
exacta en 3 y me sobra 1
es decir que si queremos convertir la
fracción 3 medios a un número mixto esto
es exactamente lo mismo que un entero un
medio que es justo lo que tengo aquí 3
entre 2 que es lo mismo que 3 por un
medio que es lo mismo que 3 medios esto
es lo mismo que un entero un medio y
justo lo puedes visualizar aquí en los
jabones tengo un jabón y medio y si
nosotros queremos fijar en la recta
numérica vamos a parados justo a la
mitad entre 1 y 2 en el punto un entero
un medio